hallo herz für kohl in meiner koch
weltweite gibt's mal wieder ein
superschnelles und super leckeres rezept
denn ich mache heute eine käse sahne
soße für spaghetti oder für andere
nudeln oder führt zum beispiel
maultaschen oder ohne film borat ich hab
das rezept nämlich schon in
friedrichshafen auf der messe auch
gekocht und habs da ihm der kennwort
zubereitet geht auch viel einfacher weil
man da nicht ständig rühren muss aber
ich mache das jetzt heute ganz normal in
einer hohen wangelin equens auch immer
top mache und es ist so ein rezept jahr
da brauchen wir wieder ganz wenige
zutaten und es ist einfach super lecker
ich zeige euch einfach mal kurze zutaten
also ich habe hier 200 milliliter sahne
100 comeback und sola käse 100 km
schafskäse und 100 gramm parmesankäse
den habe ich jetzt auch schon in der
kennwort klein gemahlen und dann brauche
ich eine gallone bisserl pfeffer das war
es auch schon
also dass man alle zutaten und meldet es
jetzt in der küchenmaschine machen wollt
dann müsst ihr einfach die zutaten dort
rein geben und das ganze auf 100 grad
stellen und dann einfach so etwa 20
minuten lang köcheln lassen
also je nachdem wie dick die soße hat
haben wollten auf dem weg sie wie sehr
ein decken sollen und jetzt lasse ich
die sache erstmal aufkochen und gibt
dann gleich die drei käsesorten mit dazu
und dabei müsste jetzt gut aufpassen
dass die sahne nicht überkocht
dann schalte ich den herd jetzt ein
bisschen zurück damit der käse auch am
trend jetzt gebe ich erstmal in goch und
sola käsereien dass auch wenn ihr den
net mögt müsste das rezept trotzdem
ausprobieren weil in der soße schmeckt
man der netz so einzeln unbedingt raus
und der bringt halt richtig so
cremigkeit und die würze und so weiter
rein es ruhig das erste mal erwische
gebe aber auch direkten schafft leese
mit 302 nämlich zusammen so ein bisserl
trim schmelzen einfach ein bisschen zu
prüfen
und den parmesan käme dann zum schluss
mit rein
er ist inzwischen auch schon die nudeln
aufgesetzt jetzt gibt's auch zum schluss
den parmesan mit dem die soße er kann
dass ich auch schon auflösen
und wenn ihr mal merkt dass die soße zu
fest geworden ist zu sehr ein gekochtes
gibt einfach nun schluss sein
das mache ich jetzt gleich
der parmesan ist jetzt geschmolzen die
nudeln habe ich abgegossen jetzt wird
sich einfach nur noch die sauce mit der
fessel treffer wenn sie ist ja schon
gehört sich aber so ein bisschen eine
kleine note bisschen oregano
wer möchte kann auch bisschen chili noch
mit dazu geben
ich hasse es halt mal draußen
ausnahmsweise und jetzt könnt ihr
entweder die nudeln mit rein geben oder
die soße dann auf dem teller auf die
nudeln geben deshalb wie ihr das möchte
ich gebe es jetzt mit rein dann sind sie
nämlich schön mit der sauce bedeckt ein
paar lasse ich aber draußen und die
sanierer marke zur gänze
schmeckt es einmal kurz durch und dann
haben wir schon innerhalb von wenigen
minuten eine schöne hauptspeise
gezaubert die total lecker schmeckt uns
sehr einfaches und vor allem braucht man
halt echt nur ganz wenige zutaten
im prinzip ist es an fünf zutaten rezept
nudeln klavier zu können
und damit das ganze schön aussieht nach
so einem pass willi kompletten drüber
und fertig ist die hauptspeise die macht
auch total satz denn der käse der stoff
total also ich bin nach so einem kleinen
teller schon ziemlich satt ganz lecker
schmeckt diese soße auch mit maultaschen
stoxx am anfang schon erwähnt oder hat
mit ganz anderen nudeln ich habe zeit
bandnudeln genommen und wird durch auch
demnächst einfach mal zeigen wie ich
meine nudeln und selber machen dass die
nudeln sind mir so ein bisschen zu heiß
zum probieren woran ich nicht da also
war ich noch ein bisschen er durchgehend
das rezept nachlesen of sales blog.de
und ich würde mich freuen wenn jetzt mal
nach macht und mir auch ein foto schickt
auf instagram oder auf facebook und wir
sehen uns dann beim nächsten mal wieder
bis bald